this is exciting because to say it
really is the first day of tip for us
and the chaos is going to begin and you
are starting it off for us which is
starting that is sure
well chaos are you talking about know
about what's so exciting that you're
doing this because you speak on so many
different levels because of what tip is
doing with this share her journey what
does it mean for you to be part of an
investment that they're doing for women
I think it's amazing I was just having a
conversation with someone saying how
hard it is for women all over the world
yeah just step out and sort of crawl out
of this thing of being second-class
citizens all our lives right like I'm a
very proud feminist and I always talk
about basically feminism is not berating
or hating men it's just saying give us
the same let me make my own decisions
and don't judge me for it the same way
men haven't been judged for so many
years so share her journey is basically
highlighting female filmmakers and
females in entertainment who have been
able to make you know their own mark and
are trying to make their own mark which
is so amazing because we don't get that
as females 15 female directors this year
at if yes I have a film premiering next
year with a first-time female director -
pretty amazing it was a female director
for her name is Paquita Rana it's her
first movie and it's a big time for you
to Bea's you have a film with at TIFF -
yes which does a film dogma which I
produce so that's this year right yes
okay so let's tell us about that well
this is a sickie means film Sikkim is a
small state in the north east of India
which never had a film industry or or
anyone who made films from there and
this is the first film ever that's come
out of that region because it's it's
very troubled with insurgency and like
troubling situations so I'm very excited
and this is a film about two kids yeah
and their perspective on the refugee
crisis on being moved from one place to
the other without understanding why
they're suddenly packing their bags and
leaving and and religion and it speaks
about all of those things but from a
kid's perspective so it's very exciting
and is this part of your production yes
well part of my production Wow and did
you run that with your mom as well yes
my mom and I are business partners and
she handles a business part of it
there's nasty stuff that I don't like
yeah this is all fun so you know when
talking about female directors if there
was one that you could work with who
would it be
oh there are so many I mean I'd love to
work with Sofia Coppola I think she's an
amazing I had I met her recently and she
just has such a great perspective as as
a woman I mean there's so many female
female direct because I would have liked
it but she's definitely one she's the
one of your friend do you like watching
films I do I don't get too much time to
do it
because I like watching the experience
on a big screen because I'm old school
that way the way I think and that never
ends up happening because I'm always
traveling right but yeah I haven't
watched a really good movie for a while
do you have a favorite from the ones
people Holmby yeah in like all-time
all-time it's always a difficult
question if there's an everyday look
wired Jeremy what's the line and you're
in a phone call isn't it romantic right
with rebel Wilson Liam Hemsworth in
you're an adult or ambassador right but
there's no such thing but yeah my
character is there's no such thing as a
Yoga ambassador but that is the point
yeah oh she takes herself that seriously
oh I see so do you do yoga
no do you go I haven't discovered it I'm
that Indian girl that doesn't really
drink too much chai or tea or doesn't do
yoga
I like the gym I do to remember and you
remember the first time we met it out
we're talking about working out do you
remember yeah we kind of showed each
other's muscles yeah but I prefer that
you know I mean I'm trying to lean
towards yoga a lot and like my family my
friends tell me that I really think that
they think need meditation in my life
maybe maybe growing up means that yeah
maybe you were talking about being in
your 30s yeah it's good though life is
crazy yeah especially with Conte
quantico you need to be working out
season three coming up yes I'm excited
about it I'm excited that it's a
13-episode season this ish don't tell
anyone but instead of 22 because then
that gives me the ability to do films
and other things that I want to do which
is how I could do these two movies
because the show is shorter and plus I'm
really excited because it's taking a
whole new revamp to see
what can we expect even I don't know in
the writers room has just come together
right now so we'll know soon but it's
gonna be a complete departure from what
we've seen in season two so I'm excited
about it you know there's a lot of talk
right now with what's happening in the
US and it's so weird that race is on the
top of the list everyone's talking about
racism and how we're treating each other
and it got me thinking about you and
even myself being in this business have
you ever dealt with it racism yeah I was
in cast in a movie because I wasn't
because they had to write a storyline
explaining why an American would be
Indian and things like that so that's
hugely racist even though you know you
might be the best person for the job
just because the color of your skin you
don't get cast so that happens and it
was extremely painful and I think it's
racism is something which is prevalent
everywhere it is just how many people
talk about it and how many people have
the courage to be able to call it out
mm-hmm do you think is changing because
you've opened a lot of doors for a lot
of women I intend to I want to kick down
some doors for a lot of women who are
immigrants from different parts of the
world who come in and want you know a
platform on global entertainment and
that's alright because you look around
you
Global Entertainment doesn't look like
one person anymore because the world
doesn't look like one person anymore
America doesn't look like one person
anymore
and there needs to be that kind of
representation and we all talk about it
yeah but we've got to fight for it yeah
you've got to say no when someone says
no I want you to do the stereotypical
part I did that I spoke to ABC very
early on and I said I want to do
something which is ethnically ambiguous
and otherwise I don't want to do it hmm
I want to be progressive when it comes
to casting for you know people who come
from outside of America and to be the
best person for the job is what's
important and that's what casting should
be like so yeah I think we need to stand
up fight for our right and not settle
anymore and not be okay with the little
parts yeah we might not get too many yah
me might have to create content for
ourselves but we're okay to do it and
that's the kind of aggression and and
that we need to look at this with you
should run for president yeah these
rules are changed on the other